they make the new kids take our photos
cuz they don't take us seriously that's
a mistake the whole world makes they
never take the girl seriously so it's
like this when you're 17 and when you're
a girl you got the whole world telling
you what to do with your body your mom
tells you change your dress it's too
fast too short too shiny the school
tells you cover your shoulders cover
your legs because they can't tell boys
to keep it in their pants and boys
they're the worse they tell you they'll
only like you if you look impossible so
you've got all these people telling you
how to wear your skin making you feel
like whatever you want is the wrong
[ __ ] thing and then you've got Spirit
Squad you know who decides our uniforms
yeah you know who choreographs our
routines we tell you how short our
skirts will be how high and tight our
talks will main house spread out we make
our Eagles I mean if you got a problem
with it well honestly that's because we
do it for ourselves for our control over
our bodies because when you're 17 you've
got to grab on to that control wherever
you can and hold tight for dear life
because they always try and take it from
you don't they
you